McLovin the poll question and then we'll
get to Golden Tate of my Detroit lines
are you for a teams or four teams in the
Final Four 56% say eight and for Notre
Dame if we went to 88 week ago Wow Wow I
might take a shot at Notre Dame I
haven't even brought Golden Tate on and
you're taking a shot at his alma mater
it's like college basketball
let's bring in Golden Tate Lions sorry
about that golden that's okay we're
having a down year
are you a fourteen playoff guy or would
you like to do eight teams oh I like the
four teams I mean I don't mind the four
team playoff I like it I like that it
makes the regular-season mean more but I
don't know if you go to eight and then
we go to eight and then we're gonna say
boy this is so great why don't we go to
ten twelve sixteen that's what would
concern me the most about it yeah I mean
that would be one of the problems but
also like 18 I mean that that seven
eight ninth 10th team are gonna all be
arguing why they should be in and how
are you gonna decide you know what eight
teams get in and then then you have
three teams three lost teams coming I
think it would just be way too much well
imagine if the NFL did a Final Four
because you'd have Dallas in there New
England Oakland and then who would be
the fourth team right now it would be
Seattle wouldn't it
oh I thought you were gonna sabi setting
you up for a Detroit should be in there
Oh number wise wait wait let's try it
again
let's try it again we had a final four
in the NFL you'd have Dallas
you'd have New England Oakland and
Detroit Lions yeah yeah yeah that's
that's the confidence I love here
I thought someone looked like my record
well you guys are waiting for yeah we're
sit in a nice place we like where we are
but do you feel like you're one of the
elite teams in the NFL I do I do I think
right now we're starting to we're trying
to peek right now I think we're playing
good fundamental fundamental football in
all three phases
I think our quarterback is is lighting
it up consistently I'm a just a guy I
thought we're just clicking I mean yeah
and I say we're I think we're clicking
because things aren't as tough as they
were early in the year I mean this was
it was really really tough on us and I
think when everyone's on their game it
just kind of happens we have so many
athletes that it just it's just hopping
who's calling you
is that Matthew Stanford calling you
golden knows my alarm going off oh he's
a Golden Tate from the Detroit Lions how
often do you ask about your first name
here in there you know that's one of the
questions that people ask when they
first see me you know where'd you get
that that name from and you know I'm I'm
a pretty joking guy and always say I
figured somebody was drunk at some point
when they may me but I'm actually a
third there's two others before me and I
mean there's really no big story on I
really do you have brothers and sisters
yes I do have have a set of twin sisters
who are at Ole Miss and I have a brother
younger brother who played at Vanderbilt
not a voice or name silver copper oh you
were ready for that one where's your
golden yeah yeah yeah but do they have
interesting names and if not then why
were you designated with the the cool
name
well I'm the oldest so in my father's
name is golden so I guess I just lucked
out and got Golden Tate the third if you
have a son are you gonna have a Golden
Tate GT the fourth you know I'm so far
away from having kids right now that I
haven't really thought about it but I
can't imagine I don't think I will have
a four maybe but as of now
I'm kind of voting against it I don't
know but we'll talk about it once once I
get married first is Stafford funny in
the huddle not not in a horrible like on
the sidelines
you know when defenses up and when we
can like friends yesterday we were able
to relax a little bit tourists in the
game versus all the other games you know
he kind of loosens up and cracks a joke
here but no you're in the huddle man
it's everything happens so quickly that
we're trying to get down to business we
also put him in their first team all bro
like there's bro quarterbacks and nerd
quarterbacks like Joe Flacco might be a
nerd
Stafford Stanford's a bro Andrew Luck
might be a nerd quarterback you follow
yeah yeah yeah Stanford's top hat back
backwards bro cargo shorts and a draft
beer oh yeah oh yeah well I'm saying
he's definitely a broker quarterback and
that's what I love about him and I think
everybody's comfortable with them
because you don't have to work you mean
he'll talk about the same stuff we
talked about we'll hang out we'll we'll
have a few beers here and there on a
special occasion you know he's he's got
a lot of swag when it comes to dressing
if you look him up and see where it's on
flame I mean the guy the guy can dress I
mean a lot of a lot of these
quarterbacks dress like they're running
for president or something but he'll
come very very proper so I like it well
like wait he doesn't do Tom Brady like
he doesn't look like that no I don't
know I don't pay attention to what Tom
Brady wear so well I mean where were you
going where is he what is Tom Brady
where that's no he's clean he well I
tell you what
Stafford does not wear ugg boots I'd say
that no no he doesn't do that
Brady Brady's clean man I mean his wife
probably dresses him you know she's the
most famous model in the world
Brady shows up like it's a runway man
yeah
I've seen Brady at the Kentucky Derby I
think you dress is really sharp sharp
but um do you guys have a dress code
because Cam Newton
had to sit out one play last night
because he didn't wear a tie on the road
oh yeah we have a dress code but it's
not to the point where you have to wear
a tie it's just like no sandals and if
you wear jeans you have to have a collar
and a jacket on things like that but
nothing like where you have to wear a
tie and that that kind of that's up they
threw a pic on that play of the first
play the game didn't it yes yeah that's
that was an epic fail
yeah but no we don't have it it's not
that strict but we do have rules and and
I got uh we pretty much stay inside the
rules because we want to keep our money
in our pockets for one do you know that
through the first 44 games with the
Lions you have more catches than any
other player in franchise history no way
really
yep yeah tell your agent there yo my new
agent is my fiancee actually I come home
yesterday you taking notes on all you
know the last four of our games when we
score how many times I touched the ball
how many times I've been throwing at and
then when we go three and ours she's
saying hey they didn't look your way
they're pulling good her first down so I
might hire my fiancee as my somebody
there she's getting more than 10 percent
right 10 percent yeah absolutely
uh keep keep it in the family wait but
you just said that you weren't close to
getting married and you got a fiance I
thought wasn't close to having kids oh
okay
does she know that you're not close to
having kids so I got you know we want to
enjoy life a little bit right yeah tell
her that you're at 254 catches through
44 games and Nate Burleson Brandon
Pettigrew our next at 189 Calvin Johnson
only had 180 set you're killing it man
Williams is out there okay all right
your fiance's name is Elise all right
Elise
hi it's great to have you on the program
I just want you to when one sees a
contract up okay here you go
254 catches through his first 44 games
that's the most of any player in
franchise history and it's not even
close where he is so I don't know if you
renegotiate this week but I think it's
something that maybe you need to get on
right now business major I'm on it
I like that now golden said if you have
kids if you have a son
that he's not sure about golden the
fourth yeah we you know what we're doing
the same on that we don't we're not
really sure either way we're not we
don't feel strongly like one way or the
other so I guess we'll figure it out one
I'm thinking Stafford Tate for a boy and
you know what you're going to you're
gonna get a lot of throws your way I'm
just saying be good play to go about it
he's ready to have twins now and ya know
I said you know since he went to Georgia
he should call one appens in one one
Georgia if he has you know he's having
girls so he like that okay Stafford take
the first capitate the first I'm gonna
actually have seen a shirt that says
Stafford Tate but it's obviously not
referring to our future denialism it's
referring to the the amazing
pass and connection combination fact
absolutely you haven't live on forever
Stafford you could even do a hyphen in
their middle name is - and Stafford -
can't a could be confused for Heisman
you know could be never Heisman hate oh
no no it's not gonna be confused for
that hey congrats go back to bed and
congrats on the season so far golden
thanks for joining us and take care of
your agent all right
I sure will thanks for having me all
right that's Golden Tate got his agent
right there sleeping with his agent
fiance the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]